good afternoon everyone
and uh welcome to this meeting of
cabinet
uh held on monday the 5th of july
i'm sure by now you're all favor all
familiar with the protocols for
meetings why am i getting an echo
do you want to try this one
is that better no
um sorry
so we have to push on so apologies for
absence
and are there any apologies for absence
apologies from councillor o'donnell and
councillor fitter
thank you anne next item on the agenda
is
disclosures of interest are there any
disclosures or interest of items on the
agenda
i'll take that as an ian sorry cancel
gentle that's fine i'll answer
anything it's not a disclosure of
interest it's just i'm aware that
um if i want to make any changes to
item 16 i need to declare them at the
beginning of the meeting
there's one word that needs to be
changed in the minutes
thank you councillor shinton uh minutes
confirm and sign the minutes of the
meeting are there any issues on the
minutes and i've had one circulated
item two to
amendment to minute 44
and that is delete
um this item is subject to calling by
the osc
uh and replace that with this item is
not subject to calling to the osc
as we as it was referred to the osce
prior to the decision being taken
and the minutes of the meeting of the
osce demonstrate
that there was extensive debate on the
issue
are there any further amendments
i'll take that as a no is everyone then
happy with the minutes of the meeting
on the seventh fifth of on the 7th of
june
we'll take that as a yes so
we move on and uh
councillor pemberton adoption of the
infrastructure funding statement and
welcome
that was well-timed
yes uh and one one thing i would just
like to say
before we consider this agenda item
is this this isn't about which projects
to
include and which will be funded this
will actually come later
councillor pemberton
apologies for uh
just bear with me for a second uh just
being right on
on the money
i'll fire up my papers so members of
cabinet um
this item before you is about the
adoption of the
infrastructure funding statement as uh
the leader has set out not uh in
relation to
specific projects this is this is this
is more
this is about setting out as we are
required legally to do
um how we will approach um
requests and assess projects that are
brought to us
uh for for use of community
infrastructure levy funds
i have uh john carefort uh
available for any specific detailed
questions
uh but the recommendation is that the
2020-21
infrastructure funding statement which
is an appendix one of you of your papers
is adopted thank you councillor
pemberton
uh councillor junaid it's it's just a
reporting back from the ovum scrutiny uh
on this item
uh at that uh meeting they the questions
were asked about
whether cycling and walking had been
adequately considered
in that infrastructure list and whether
climate change had been added
as considered uh we were assured that
they had been
uh at that at the ovian scrutiny
committee an update was requested on the
community infrastructure
levy allocated to number one eastern
place
and the policy manager uh agreed to
request an
update uh for the councillor that raised
that
um but it's something that we would like
to keep an eye on
and a progress report was requested
on allocated but unspent allocations
and we would like to have that requested
and brought forward to a future meet at
the overview and scrutiny committee
meeting
thank you thank you council of pemberton
do you wish to make any comments in
response
uh well i think those are
as far as i can see those are matters
aside too rather than
to the heart of the 2020 2021
infrastructure
funding statement itself um
officers have already given osc this
morning as you've indicated
an assurance that is in all matters
climate change runs to the heart of
every single policy of this council and
the
our approach to infrastructure
requests on the sill is no different
from that
and clearly that taps into
things such as walking and cycling
options but i would remind
members of cabinet and overview and
scrutiny committee
um it it is not it is not our role
to design these projects it is our role
to
assess projects that are brought to us
by partners and we invite partners to
discuss with us at early doors potential
projects that may be appropriate for sil
so in some respects we're not entirely
in control of
of that part of the process but i'm
happy to give the assurance
that both climate change and uh
achieving modal shift from internal
combustion engine cars is
uh a clear priority for the organization
similarly in relation to any specific
project it is of course uh for overview
and scrutiny
to request and will be provided with
updates as appropriate
um i think what i'd probably like to do
in terms of some general progress on
um on funds i think that starts to talk
to the operational delivery
once funds have been agreed so perhaps
with uh your forbearance leader i
would i would welcome the opportunity
for a discussion with
uh the chair and or vice chair of
overview and scrutiny to understand
exactly what it is that is being
requested so that it can add value
as far as overview and scrutiny is
concerned uh and ensure that we are
you know it is it is covering the the
right thing to
speak so if if if that would be
appropriate
offline setup a discussion about what
that might look like
thank you councillor pemberton
councillor parry
thank you thank you leader um i'd just
like to take this opportunity to thank
the portfolio holder and
joe and john and the team for pulling
this excellent piece of work together
i appreciate we're not here to discuss
individual projects
but i would just like to say that i
really welcome that wellsborne has put
forward two particular projects
particularly in the leisure field as a
main rural center wellsborne
is is the only um
rural centre large village that has not
received any funding whatsoever for its
leisure facilities and has actually had
to raise the precept
amongst villagers to build a sports
facility
so the fact that it's it's put forward
um a couple of projects i welcome
and i hope perhaps officers and cabinet
members and members of committee might
take note
at the appropriate time thank you leader
thank you councillor parry
uh if there are no further comments then
the recommendation for council
on page seven that the infrastructure
funding statement
2020 to 21 are set out in appendix won't
be adopted
can i have your agreement members of
cabinet please
thank you members of cabinet so we move
on to item
five which is development requirements
supplementary planning document
uh latest draft of part w gypsies and
travelers and traveling show people
and can i just say that this is not
about the consideration of individual
sites
or about enforcement this is about
just looking at the development
requirements supplementary planning
document
and please note the final version
will be presented in october 21
so this is the recommendation as things
stand at the moment
uh council of pemberton thank you leader
um yes just to um for the benefit
benefit of members of
of cabinet and observers um
yes um as as members will know we have
been
uh working up a development requirement
supplementary planning document
um to cover the the needs of gypsies and
travelers and travelling show people
and it is sensible that that
supplementary planning document um
is not just inward looking but it sort
of takes a holistic view and for that
reason
uh in conjunction with the portfolio
holder for housing and well-being
council of barca it's been agreed that
we should
um at this point note rather than
formally adopt
uh the the spd that enables us to
have the benefit of our planning
officers being able to give
life to the um the the
the detail in the spd but does enable us
as we are working up a revised housing
strategy
to ensure that that is dovetailed
specifically with the housing strategy
so that we don't actually have the sort
of law of unintended consequences
applying so
uh it is for that reason that we're into
noting rather than adopting at this
point
uh i see counselor cargill has a
question i'll thank you for that
counselor barker your name's also
on this is lead member do you wish to
add anything to what council of
pemberton has said
i have very little to add except that
that's exactly what's going to happen
it's to it's because we need to dovetail
into the housing strategy
and the unintended consequences would be
if we had
sites for gypsy and travelers which
weren't
the sort of sites that we were prepared
to allow housing to go on so we've got
to make it work
together thank you councillor barker
councillor junaid and then council
apparent at the ovn scrutiny question
the question was raised was the added
was the relationship with warwickshire
county council adequate
um we would like to maintain that to
make sure because we
that the comments were made that that
was quite essential to
achieving the the insights that you
require
counselor barker would you care to
respond to that
as you are a twin hatter with my twin
hat on it hasn't worked so far
um sites are very very hard to come by
and we'll talk to anybody who's prepared
to provide sites
thank you councillor parry thank you
leader
i just wondered whether there could be
any further clarification
when uh this report makes reference to
reasonable proximity of sites to local
services and facilities
um i just wonder when this comes forward
whether it could be
just clarified in terms of a specific
distance
only because i'm just a bit concerned
that reasonable proximity
is open to um it's very ambiguous
it makes reference on page 65
and it's on page 13 of the report that's
all i ask for thank you for further
clarification
thank you council of paris councillor
pemberton
thank you leader and thank you council
parry before
answering that i would just also in
relation to junior's comments on behalf
of overview and scrutiny
reiterate councillor barca's comments
and to observe that our officers
have over a considerable period of time
up to our most senior officers uh been
working
extremely hard to engage with our county
council colleagues
to work in partnership with us to bring
forward
appropriate sites that they may have
within their
ownership for the delivery of
sustainable
and appropriate gypsy traveller and
travelling show people sites
across this district that work continues
and we will not be backwards in coming
forwards in in those discussions
um cancer parry i i understand and hear
what you
say um one of the challenges of course
is that if we are prescriptive and we
say it's 1.76 kilometers
from the village center and there's a
site that's 1.78 kilometers
we we we can pull ourselves into some
difficulties and challenges
and there is an element of flexibility
deliberately built in
uh to allow for us on a case-by-case
basis to
with our planning development colleagues
to
come to a judgment potentially with a
planning committee as to the
appropriateness of a particular location
i do hear what you say and i'm sure that
uh mr carefort and uh
uh will will note that and if there is
any
further refinement that can
appropriately be made
then i think that officers will look at
that having said that however
um it is something that we have gone
we've gone around
the circle a little bit and and this is
the sort of um
the most um pragmatic
wording but i hear what you say and we
we will we will look at that
again but i i can make no firm promise
thank you thank you councillor pemberton
councillor cargill
thank you and i look like the shrouds on
the uh
the microphone so very interesting thank
you very much
okay um i think i
uh members may be aware that ulster's
suffered from a
an illegal encampment on the rugby pitch
uh
the last week and it has devastated the
club in the grounds
uh for a small club the thousands and
thousands of pounds
necessary to recover
a playing pitch and the on the buildings
etc
is possibly unsustainable for some small
organizations they could go underneath
therefore it's vital that we do have
these transit sites in place now i know
and i have been working with
my colleagues at county when i was a
county councillor trying to get this and
they will say that
we're not coming forward and we're
saying they're not coming forward we
really need to get a good dialogue
going here because it's too important
these these people are coming on
destroying areas
and i mean destroying them and because
there are there's nothing we can do
now currently we don't have any
transition sites correctly if i'm wrong
in south workshop i i don't hear anyone
saying anything of that
we must split this into two the majority
of this i
i'm quite happy with whereas we're
trying to identify
sites for pictures whereas we are also
trying to get
transition sites where we can actually
force them and move them on
as opposed to going over to rugby clubs
and football pitchers and the like
there is a law change coming forward
which is the trespass law
and that will change it from for example
a civil defense to a
criminal offence but again we got the
resources to be able to
move these people on it's not a simple
thing we know that
and sometimes legislation is put in and
again we were talking about a
one-size-fits-all and
law of unintended consequences the
actual
law of this one is european law if roma
if i'm a councillor cargill i think
you've made your point
and this is about noting the latest
version of part w
so uh if we can move on we've got to do
something about this chair
you are heard counselor cargill however
with that if there are no more comments
or observations the recommendation on
page 47
are covering it in favor of that
thank you members of cabinet so moving
on to item
six the clinton neighborhood development
plan
and it is councillor pemberton again
and this is about
schedule of significant comments be
endorsed
so over to you councillor pemberton once
again
quinton has gone through is going
through its neighborhood development
plan process
and has reached the point where uh in
advance of
uh submission um uh that we are
uh we have we've been provided with uh
copies to enable us under regulation 14
um to make our own responses and
this report is seeking uh
your confirmation that the schedule of
comments that you find at appendix one
are endorsed and are submitted as our
formal response
to the pre-consultation process
for the quinton neighborhood development
plan at
appendix 2 and the local green space
assessment of appendix 3.
at that point i will leave it for any
questions observations
and again policy planning officers are
available
for any specific detailed questions
thank you councillor pemberton
councillor harvey
thank you leader uh one question one
observation one question
um paragraph five one two
uh neighborhood plans must be compatible
with eu obligations
can it be confirmed that we still have
an obligation
to comply with eu obligation i don't
know that we
whether we do or whether we don't and
perhaps more seriously however is um on
page 75 and there's a reference to
under paragraph 6 1 12 page 21
there's a reference there to we believe
that quentin will have met
25 its 25 target
and contributed 110 homes
um mind i know where this comes from
um but i think it's essentially a
misunderstanding
um and i i wouldn't want to see the
basis of misunderstanding perpetuated
in an ndp um
this particular point comes up it's made
repeatedly at
uh in relation to planning applications
and i've done it myself i've
i've been i've been involved so i'm as
guilty as anybody else
um referring to the proportion of
houses that are required under the core
strategy
distributed around around the district
uh in relation to 13
and parishes work out a number and say
that is their target
when that evidence when that fact is put
in front of a
of a planning committee or certainly
planning inspectors
planning inspectors always turn around
and say this is
not a minute this is not a maximum it is
it is a minimum and it's there is no
maximum
what concerns me is that but in the
wording that is
used we are allowing or we're on the
verge of allowing
an ndp to go forward
on the basis it says something which is
not
true clinton
has not met its target for 110
quentin may have suffered in their terms
110 but we must get away from from
um writing down something as fact
when it is not fact and it applies to
the next item
as well thank you uh councillor harvey
council of pemberton do you wish to
respond
so i think i'll i will bring john keford
in but i think what you're
uh if i if i take your points um you're
looking to
for it to be the reference to be um
a minimum number rather than a maximum
um i
uh and and i'm quite comfortable with
that but i think perhaps uh if mr
carefully would like to
to comment on some on on that for me
mr clearford welcome to the meeting
afternoon members uh thank you leader
um yes i i take the
[Music]
can you hear me now any luck
i've got my microphone on
sorry john we can't hear you
[Laughter]
uh afternoon members uh thank you leader
um yes i i take the point
um it is a a minimum figure
to be achieved and uh whether members
are
uh would prefer uh one of the comments
that we
we send back to to quinton and the ndp
is just to
nuance that language so it's power
6.1.18 i think is the uh
the references are spotted on page 21 of
the
mtp itself um whether
the best approach is uh if members are
happy that
officers agree with the portfolio holder
some revised wording
and we we then with that amendment
they're the comments we submit back to
the parish
thank you uh mr kevin i just want to
bring councillor kettle in at this point
um i completely understand councillor
harvey's point
but actually what the inspector did say
um in his interim report
which did form part of his final report
because he cross refers back to it
was in terms of lsv's that the 2000
number he was going to keep in
to give some guidance and surety
to developers and i haven't got the
actual text in front of me because my
laptop's just
batteries have run out but to give
guidance and surety to both
residents and developers um
about the numbers each village or at
each lsv should be
entitled to expect and every single
inspector's report subsequent to
publication of the core strategy
underpinned by uh the inspector's report
seems to have ignored that critical
paragraph
so i completely understand where
councillor harvey is coming from
uh but i can't remember the inspector's
name but he did quite clearly identify
that 2000
across the ls fees was the right number
and we must never forget that as a
district until we have a new course
strategy
which may be sooner rather than later i
accept but i would request
those uh who are involved in this
process and i see mr care for looking
slightly quizzical at this point
but it is a point i did um i i wasn't
expecting cancer how to bring it up but
i think it is really important to
remember that
fine counselor pemberton thank you uh
thank you thank you councillor kettle
and
um yep we're we're all aware of the
interim report and the numbers that were
put in there
the trouble is of course that planning
inspectors
are entitled to make the decisions based
on the facts that they have before them
on each individual case
and bluntly can could ignore that 2000
number
and and it is and partly for that reason
um i think that what we have we have had
on a number of occasions
is given that context
and given subsequent neighborhood
development plans
um a feeling of uh being somewhat
shortchanged
in certain communities where they could
be in a position where there is a
proposition that
puts them in a position where more than
their quote percentage of the 2000 is on
the table
um and it's quite difficult to to to
make the case that
well the inspector can come to whatever
decision they really like
on each given in you know each given
application site because
um the core strategy is not a binding
precedent
in that sense uh that that we all might
wish
it is a framework it is a plan and a
guidance
so i think given that um i am quite
minded
to be supportive of councillor harvey's
approach to ensure that there is a more
nuanced
understanding for communities going
forward
about the true position and it reflects
the reality on the ground
of planning inspector decisions where
if we got north if you know getting
north of 2000 would not make any
planning
inspectors decision uh open to challenge
at judicial review unless
unless uh mr grafton is going to tell me
otherwise but i think
we probably should be reflecting the
reality on the ground
i do note and i have a lot of sympathy
with the comment that you make
but we we perhaps should be actually
giving a better steer on that particular
point
and if members of cabinet are
comfortable then in liaison with
officer colleagues we i will sign off on
a more nuanced update there and we'll
take it as read that that applies to
some of them as well
that sounds like a reasonable proposal
to me councillor pemberton
with that members of cabinet can i have
your agreement to the recommendation on
page
69 uh taking on board councillor
pemberton's comments
thank you members of cabinet uh now we
move on to these
item seven the southern neighborhood
development plan
pre-submission consultation responses
and once again this is council of
pemberton
thank you leader um southern
neighborhood development plan process is
at the same point
uh we are now making our significant
comments uh which are at appendix one
uh for members of cabinet i would uh
draw your attention
to the fact that both ward members uh
have
seen and are comfortable and have had
input to the amendment comments
um and i would i would
request that you support the
recommendation that the the comments at
appendix one
um and and the are
approved as our formal response thank
you thank you council of pemberton
it is nice to see that southern have
submitted
or are beginning the process of
submitting a neighborhood development
plan
uh so recommendation on page 79
how are members of cabinet uh in support
of that recommendation please
thank you members of cabinet uh agenda
item eight
shared climate change ambitions for
south warwickshire
councillor shenton thank you leader
um hopefully that's not whistling if it
is i'll
take my hearing aids
i'll stay this far back and the paper
highlights the issues that we face as a
district
and some areas that we should consider
but many of the areas
are outside of our control demanding
central government policy legislation
and hard cash other areas such as
say agriculture which i know councillor
kettle might
have a few words to say about are
highlighted
only because our area is rural and rich
in agriculture
and farming what i will say
is that the government and the nfu
appear to be aligned
on the great strides made by the
industry in soil quality
biodiversity wilding etc
this part of the climate agenda is a
national issue
anyway and the farming community i will
say are at the forefront of
technological changes that result
in lower emissions the second
point i'd like to make is that
investment in
electricity and the infrastructure to
deliberate electricity is an issue
and i know that our leader has probably
some comments to make on that and some
thoughts to make on that
as well plus thirdly um
we will be receiving data
from the met office which will obviously
affect what we do going forward because
it will be
more local and nuanced for stratford
or and and warwickshire the paper in
itself is not an actions list or a list
of commitments but is a good basis on
which to create a work program by the
autumn
so that we can get on with the practical
and sensible actions
that will help to reduce the effects of
climate change
but be under no illusion though we
cannot work alone and neither will our
actions on
excuse me on their own change the world
in which we current
they are living in as we need everyone
around the world to take part and do
their bit if we are to have any chance
of limiting global temperature increases
to below three degrees
let alone two degrees when measured
against pre-industrial levels
the biggest polluters obviously are
vehicles and we have to be pragmatic
about this as we live in a rural
district
where public transport is not sufficient
to get residents
out of their cars so there will be
compromises
and a coherent transport policy will be
needed to address
issues such as park and ride clean air
zones emission based parking charges etc
the list is literally endless
the target in the paper of 55
is highly ambitious as the anthesis
report highlights
but i will add that that does fall well
short of the paris agreement
and should be regarded as the minimum at
this stage
but one thing is for certain we'll need
more data and the science and technology
behind the solutions so that we can
advance at a greater pace than it
is now as we're already at global
increases of roughly 1.2 degrees
with the paris agreement suggesting that
limit it should be limited to 1.5
and 2 as a worst case
it's clear that the climate change
committee the international energy
authority and the un are all forecasting
that unless countries pick up the pace
and invest more in green solutions then
we could see four degree increases
as the average which would be
catastrophic
this is one of the reasons why we asked
for warrick our partners within this
paper to strengthen
the piece on adaptation
the paper is therefore an attempt to
finally move from all the talking to the
doing
and and action with a detailed work
program scheduled as i mentioned by the
autumn
the paper's not perfect it could never
be due to the complexity
and increasing understanding of the
catalysts and actions needed
so the work program will be updated or
refreshed regularly to take account of
the advances
in science data and information
i asked members to accept the
recommendation on page 79
as it stands as we have a consensus
across
the party across committees and
hopefully
with warwick on wednesday with their osc
and on thursday with their cabinet
as of last night there were no
objections or amendments to the paper
at warwick so this hopefully will send
out a clear and
unambiguous message to everyone that we
are
serious about climate change we'll be
led by the government
science data and look to do what we can
do with the resources that we have
being sensible and pragmatic but with a
clear eye on the goal to reduce
emissions
we need help from every resident and
every business sector
and reasons for and not reasons for
not moving forward and doing something
so i'm happy to take any questions on
paper
and i'll just clarify something
councillor shenton
that actually this paper is not set in
stone
uh if we approve it and work approved it
nevertheless as new information becomes
available
as the situation changes then this paper
will actually be revised
absolutely there's no question about
that i mean it is uh
dave baba myself and my opposite number
of warwick have spoken about
that science and the data will change
this paper significantly
i mean one of the concerns i must admit
i have is about electricity supply into
the district
the more i hear the more that may well
be
a significant constraint on what we can
achieve
so counselor pemberton
mr grafton probably told me otherwise
but i don't think i have declared an
interest on this being a
being a farmer and a major part of this
um
paper being about agriculture um
if mr graff you'll correct me if i'm
wrong on that assumption
um i think having declared the interest
it's not something that you should be
worried about
thank you in terms of speaking or voting
uh thank you
um firstly um
i do have an interest and agriculture
looking at the
comments made about drier summers wetter
winters more intense storms
agriculture is probably the sector which
is most affected in the short
term as an industry as a business by
climate change
um over the last four or five years
there's been a distinct change in
pattern because we look at it on a
regular basis
um and wetter's winters have been
considerably wetter
and that does have an impact on output
and food production
and that is why the nfu have already
promoted their own document
achieving net zero because as an
organization
the industry completely recognizes the
other fundamental
importance of us working together
having said that what concerns me
is that agriculture uh is estimated
in the paper to producing
net sorry i'm just waiting to see what's
gonna happen
net uh ghgs of about 3.3 percent
according to the paper that compares to
um the combined buildings of 40
and transport of 45 percent um
and therefore i am concerned as to why
it is focusing on agriculture
and i am informed by mr barber but the
reason for that
is that the scatter program on which the
analysis is based
was developed for urban areas and
therefore
misses data from non uh urban
more rural areas which of course
stratford clearly is
and what whilst i completely endorse the
ambitions
using a program designed for an urban
area to understand the
rural the implications of the rural area
does not
strike me as the logical way to go
forward
so yes the ambitions are right but we
need to make sure the methodology
we use going forward properly reflects
the rural nature of stratford but also
to a lesser extent
uh warwick
um i'd then like to go on to the fact
that the data
used for the agricultural sector was
produced in 2016.
now as a member of the industry i know i
get chased by the nfu
or not by the interview the minivan uh
defra
and i got another letter this morning uh
about quarterly returns annual returns
on livestock numbers etcetera
there must be more recent data than
five-year-old data available
to conduct this analysis and
had that data being used and had there
been a correlation between the nfu's
published data um
what the pro what the program is
suggesting
is that agriculture needs to reduce its
ghg emissions by 12
absolutely i've got a problem with that
but what the nfu have established and
it's a public document and i'm sure will
be open to scrutiny
is agriculture since that time has
already reduced
managed to reduce gh emissions
by seven and a half percent so we are
two-thirds towards the goal
that this paper is setting out
so when we move forward to the next
situation
i think we think we need to look at the
sectors which are
producing more ghgs in this district in
this case
fundamentally more and if we're going to
talk about agriculture
we need to ensure that the data we're
using is accurate
up-to-date and is relevant
to the extensive farm practices used
in warwickshire and doesn't reflect
the average
which of course includes the south
american and north american
feedlot systems which are hugely
different in terms of ghg emissions
now i have asked that question i haven't
yet had a response as to whether the
data is extracted
but there are also a lot of knock-on
effects which seem to be ignored in that
analysis about agriculture
there any reason i'm raising this is we
are a rural sector
and if we're going to move forward there
are an awful lot of businesses
in our district
who are agriculturally based and we we
we must
get their support or that moving forward
and i think to do that we need to
demonstrate we're using the best
possible data
and not by public perception
as to why agriculture is the only one in
this report picked up
i think councillor kettle your points
are extremely well made
uh councillor shenton the next iteration
of this paper i think
really does need to pick up that point
and i think one of the other points that
counselor kettle made which is
exceedingly relevant
is that an awful lot of the data refers
to urban areas
not to rural areas and
recently i have been on a number of
seminars
run by midlands correct connect it is
absolutely fascinating how they mention
uh the transport emissions in rural
areas
and then you point out to them that yes
we have these things called motorways
running through the rural areas which
account for quite a lot
of the emissions from transport and
somehow
i cannot see his closing being allowed
to close the motorways
just to reduce our emissions so i think
that the two points there that on the
next iteration
really do need to be picked up and
bottomed
councillor junit
at the ovun scrutiny committee i did
express
my disappointment and
frustration with the amount of progress
that has been made up to now
um i i take actually i take uh
councillor kettle's point
well uh the anthesis report uses
government statistics but some of them
are
outdated statistics quite by some years
but it is and we must make any progress
must be made on
as as up-to-date information as is
possible
it just strikes me looking at some of
the items in the report
that have been done is that warwick
district council appears
i haven't got the total evidence on that
but it appears to have made more
progress
on this agenda item than stratfor
district council has
and and i would like to see stratford be
the best of the best as it always what
used to be
in the days of local agenda 21
and just as a put small aside
i actually came in here earlier this
week and the radiators were on in this
building
uh and just that was a smaller side but
it just shows that we do need to look at
um our energy use for this building for
example
there may be the uh in future there may
be a different building
who knows but part of
part of addressing climate change is to
do uh a big you know
look at energy efficiency heat
efficiency etc i will declare that i am
a trustee of act on energy so
um you know there is i have to say that
because
i again that was set up by this council
um in 1999 i believe
uh and um and the council works with it
so i will
will um declare that but what the other
point
um that i would like to say is that if
you are going to go for drastic action
and drastic action probably will be
needed
um you it's important that you carry
residents with you
it's absolutely crucial that you carry
resources with you
you have to show that there's benefits
as well as um
as well as negative effects so for
example on
on energy efficiency you can reduce your
bills if you say
save on energy so but it is important
absolutely crucial so i would like to
make sure that any reiteration of this
um this report not only carries the most
up-to-date statistics
possible but it also emphasizes the
that this council will and warwick
district council will work with its
benef
with its residents to do what is uh what
is possible
uh and um and that we get we
we um we we i do not want to see
this council outshined by other councils
let's put it that way
thank you councillor junior i've now
councillor pemberton councillor carl
gillian back to council of shenzhen
okay uh appearances can be deceptive and
i'm done with this thing that says
warwick were
way ahead of us on this councillor
junior you sat in this very room
two or three weeks ago where i told dave
barber
that there was a red line around
adaptations
it's not far off us having to drag
warwick kicking and screaming to the
concept of adapting
to the changes that are inevitably going
to come about
by our by this species actions already
and to con constantly talk up warwick
who are really good at being
you know the messaging around this we're
not quite so good
i think you know councillor shenton you
know was absolutely right
you know we're trying to get to the
doing i'm leading with john cook on a
south warwickshire plan
that has climate change at the heart of
it and to suggest that we on
we are we are dragging our feet on this
i as i say i'm done with that as a
notion
we are trying to make a difference here
this is a 30-year project
and we are setting some ambitions and
these ambitions will change
as the science changes as we get better
data it is no
i mean it is no surprise whatsoever that
the data so far
is based on urban environments that's
that's
that can't be a shock to anybody um but
as we move through we will have more
sophisticated data
the net office that we have engaged with
to help support and shape the south
warwickshire plan
we are the first authority in the
country to engage with the met office
and it's modeling on climate change
and we are certainly the first rural
authority to have that conversation
so um my view of all of this is that
this is
an ambitions paper it is an ambitious
paper that we have had to negotiate with
our partners in
warwick to get to a first start point
to move forward it is an ambitions paper
and its ambitions
will be refined and when we look when
those of us who are in these seats in 30
years time look back on this
there will be dozens of iterations of
this there will be changes
in the light of science in the light of
development
so um let us not
think that this is the the end of it i
am sort of
minded of churchill but i'm not going to
bore you with that
this is a start point this will be a con
this will be an evolving a living
document a living approach
let's accept it for what it is
as a start point that enables us to
start getting the doing done
and for us to enable the doing to be
done by all of those
that we influence um so i would commend
this paper
as a as a good piece of work by officers
in both authorities strong negotiation
by the portfolio holder with his
counterpart
let's move on let's get it in front of
council let's start
to make some changes thank you
councillor pemberton
and i do take the point she made about
adaptation
and it does appear that recently
adaptation has
moved far far further up the agenda
which it can only be good news uh
councillor cargill
councillor shenton do you want to work
just close this part
please um i couldn't have put it better
than
mr churchill himself again please don't
i did just want to say
if if you look at page 95 on the
statement of an intent right at the very
bottom it does say
so as we set these ambitions we
understand that there are many
uncertainties
and we recognize that the path towards
net zero
will need to change as the context
changes
that we will be driven by up-to-date
data
and the science we won't be picking on
uh farming and agriculture in any way or
any other
industry we will pick we will there are
there are other
areas that hopefully will be easier to
deal with and to get on with
we have to deal with and do what we can
do
with our own resources agriculture
farming
was as i said before is only highlighted
because of our rural area
it wasn't meant to be the
the focal point of what we're we're
overwhelmed
thank you councillor shenton and i think
there's been
a good discussion on this particular
paper
and i'm sure you've picked up an awful
lot of aries that the next iteration of
this paper
will very very clearly address
so counselor kettle do you have one very
last comment briefly please
uh i wonder if the chairman would be
prepared to support
uh a summary of my comments a precede to
be included in the minutes
i think there should be no problem in
actually uh
including the press of your comments in
the minutes because then it is recorded
and we then know what needs to be done
in the next iteration of the paper
in fact i think capturing many of the
comments that were made around
the table would be valuable because they
will
form input into the next iteration of
the paper
and let's be quite honest about it it is
very important we get this stuff right
climate change is going to be very
serious
not only for us but for the next
generations in particular
so with that uh members of
councillor harvey thank you don't wish
to prolong it but
i do have some views i'd like to stay to
put on record if possible
um this is an area where
the the 80 20 rule uh operates uh almost
precisely in paragraph 3.2.2
and this reference to road transport in
buildings on the one hand
together are roughly 80 percent of the
task and that's where
large measure in large measure
adaptations can take place um
uh in in setting ambitions they have to
be stretching
they have to be challenging but they
have to be realistic i'm i'm concerned
uh that uh our ambitions will
overstretch
our capabilities i turn specifically to
the question of
fossil fuels the biggest change we've
had in fossil fuel
use in in the uk in the last 10 15 years
has been the shift away from coal almost
totally complete now
to to renewable sources that is a policy
which i doubt whether any particular
district council had
any particular influence over whatever
that was a matter of government
control and in relation to these items
and these items in relation to to road
transport we all know what the issue is
it's petrol and diesel and it's got to
go to electric in one form another at
some pace or another
subject to availability of supply when
it comes to buildings
both residential and industrial it's a
matter of design and regulation
that's fine but we have a huge huge
stock of industrial buildings and
residential houses
millions tens of millions which will
need
uh insulation and gas boilers ripping
out and all the rest
and my overwhelming concern is that
um there is evidence already the the
recent referendum in switzerland
everybody knows what the arguments were
but the swiss rejected the
the actions they weren't prepared and
i'm i'm concerned that we can't
take our residence with us because the
cost
and the cost will bear heaven most
heavily
on those who are least able to afford
the changes
so my concern is that we keep our
ambitions
in proportion to our resources and our
capabilities
and that we to achieve the significant
changes that stratford will need to
to to deliver on these sort of targets
we would absolutely need
government support cash
persuasion and energy using the word
loosely
it really is important that we realize
what we can do
as a district but what we can't do on
our own
as a district and for me there's a these
these ambitions need to be
achievable and realistic so have regard
to our resources please
thank you councillor harvey i think your
points are exceedingly well made
for an awful lot of this it is central
government that is going to have to
drive it
so with that if there are no final
comments
in that case recommendation on page 91
are you in agreement with the
recommendation on page 91 members of
cabinet
thank you members of cabinet so moving
on he says finding his agenda
uh we now move to councillor harvey
agenda item nine capital out turn 20
20 to 21 and capital slippage councillor
harvey
thank you leader i realize i've got four
papers in quick succession so i'm going
to keep
the comments on each one uh relatively
uh relatively brief
um the purpose of this particular paper
is to inform members
of the amount of money spent by the
council on capital expenditure items
in the last accounting period that is to
the end of march
2021 i'm pleased to see
mr snow is about to save my bacon should
it need saving
this amounted to 2.3 million pounds as
shown in the third line of table 1.
i draw attention to paragraph 1.5
and the underlying details set out in
appendix 1 for the year ended
31 march 2021 these details confirm that
capital expenditure of 2.3 million
pounds was made
in the last financial year once section
106 expenditure
is included the second purpose of the
paper
is to seek the cabinet's agreement to
amounts of capital expenditures that
should not be spent
that could not be spent in 2020 2021
to be carried forward to be available
for commitment in the current financial
year
of 21.22 these are referred to as items
of slippage and they amount to 8.5
million pounds as summarized in table
3 that are in paragraph 2.3.1
and accounted for by head of the
relevant functions in appendix 3.
briefing details of the reasons
supporting significant items
that are sought to be carried forward
are set out in paragraphs 2.11
to 2.110 there are various reasons
for the for these uh amounts requested
to be carried forward
which i'm sure mr snow would be happy to
provide further explanation
if required given current practices i
asked members therefore to accept the
recommendation
that the capital budget for 2122 be
increased by
eight million five hundred thirty seven
thousand six hundred and seventy five
pounds for the reasons set out
and as recommended in the paper
thank you councillor harvey and i do
know that uh
five million of the slippage is down to
the materials recycling center
which i really don't think is going to
go away
thanks for joining just a a couple of
small items really one is that uh
several of these items on here
are relate to an item that i brought up
before that ov and scrutiny
asked that sill uh allocations um that
were under spent this year
uh should be we should have updates on
uh so for example the
various flood risk management uh schemes
uh and um
at the young place uh scheme that we
would like to be kept
uh updated making a comment on my own
behalf
just a query actually on the planned
maintenance which is 2.1.3
which is um underspend there to be
carried forward
is there any of that for reducing energy
costs in this building
by any chance
chairman if i can respond yeah
absolutely some of the costs
in relation to the plan maintenance will
be to reduce energy costs we have put
new light in in the area in the first
floor particularly
which we've now made is a secure area
that's reduced
reducing the cost of lighting
i have to say there's an overall picture
i think given
a uh kobi'd
restrictions this year the slippages
don't particularly surprise me
so if there are no further comments or
questions from cabinet the
recommendation on page 107
uh our members of cabinet happy with
that
thank you so moving on councillor harvey
again draft
draft revenue out turn 20 20
21. thank you leader
the purpose of this paper is threefold
first to ask cabinet members to note the
draft financial results for the last
year
second to seek the cabinet's agreement
for the resultant variance being added
to the general fund
reserves and third to ask members of the
cabinet to note the amounts to be added
to the council's earmarked reserves
in relation to the first purpose the
past financial year was predominated
by the effect of the kovid panic
this led to higher costs in some areas
and significant shortfalls
against budgeted revenue the key
paragraph in the paper is paragraph 1.4
which reports that the council incurred
a net deficit of 2 million 232
654 pounds and table 1 itemizes the most
significant
areas table 2 on page 130 sets out the
basis
of the council's general reserve revenue
reserve
at the end of march 2021 of 7.8 million
pounds in round terms
and the council's net expenditure last
year was actually 19.1 million pounds
because some of the expenditure items
could not be undertaken during the year
as has been provided for in the approved
budget it's requested
the sum of seven million one about 198
535 pounds as optimized in table three
be set against the 2021 budget and be
included
in the earmarked reserves to enable the
items of the 10
intended expenditure to be undertaken in
the current year
subject therefore to any questions
members of the cabinet may have
i ask that the recommendations are as
set out on page
127 be approved council
councillor junior uh i'm not an
accountant so
uh i may have got this wrong but i i
hope uh that
um i haven't um i last year
there were reports of a deficit of
various sums of deficit that ranged from
about 8.1 million
to 2.2 million that were reported
uh but that that just appeared to have
changed we've got the
uh update on item 10 uh honor be here
before us
and in my um looking at it it appears
that there is a surplus
of 1 million but that 3.2 million
is being put into earmarked reserves
which then turns that into a loss of 2.2
million
can i see clarification on that one uh
have we actually made a
million pound uh you know over the year
or are we in deficit because it does
appear to be
the the sums have changed enormously
over the last year
and i would like to have clarification
to be fair councillor junior given the
year we've had it's not surprising the
numbers have changed considerably
councillor harvey do you wish to respond
or no i think
this calls for a reply from an
accountant
do you wish to respond first yes i'll
i'll
go first thank you um yeah i mean the
figures have
varied a lot during the year and the
figures the variances put out it didn't
vary during the year um going back to
mike got his mic on
you did you put your mic on that one
yeah okay thank you how better
right so going back some sort of 12
months we were sort of talking about an
8 million pound
shortfall in income was the figures that
were being very much put out then at the
time it was sort of talking about the
car park income
it wasn't sort of looking at the net
position it was very much sort of
concentrating on all these different
income
uh shortfalls that we were looking at at
the time and we know that during the
year things have changed a lot the
government
has specifically come up with some sort
of ring fence
or support packages which have helped
and in terms of income there was the
income compensation scheme as well
whereby
of sort of things like car park income
we were able to
uh receive i think it was 75 percent of
95 percent
of the budgeted sort of shortfall so you
know so we've had things have moved
a lot into you know to the advantages of
local authorities i mean having said
that i do think you know
um stratfor district council being one
of the first to sort of put these
positions uh these figures out there
in the national position probably isn't
undoubtedly helped local governments
across the board
to get some of this compensation that um
that you know all local authorities have
benefited from so
you know something and obviously it was
right at that time i think to
you know based on the information that
we had at the time to actually
put out that uh what's obviously turned
out to be a sort of
um too pessimistic position
um turning to the other um aspects here
i mean yes the you know we're looking at
a sort of net understand there of
net overspend of 2.2 million but has
pointed out that is after various money
has been transferred to
various earmark reserves now the makeup
of those
sums transferred to the earmark reserve
some of it is
in respect of some sort or specific
projects which have slipped
from last year from the old year to the
new year
but of course there is a large element
of it which is specific covid funding
which is um which we've received from
the government and
a lot of that has actually got to be
used for paying things like the business
grant schemes which we're paying in the
current year
so if we didn't actually put that money
into an earmarked reserve
we still got to do those schemes i think
we've still got to do those business
grant schemes in this year in fact we've
been doing them
and without that we would obviously you
know we'd be declaring a surplus in the
old year but of course then we'd be
instantly into this
more def deficit position in the new
year so i think it's
um as well into accountants speak to
actually put that money
into the emr reserve does make the
position
um for the the 2.2 net overspend but it
does present i think a more balanced
position because you know as i say the
the income that we've had for those
business grants and such things
you know that was actually bonus income
but it is really money that we should be
carrying forward to the new year
so that's it thank you mr snow just say
that's just final point that is what we
tried to reflect in the
addendum paper as well which came out
thank you mr snow i think the
one of the points you made there which
is extremely
valid is the fact that when we were
doing the early projections about how
much revenue we'd lost
that really was a very powerful message
to get across the government
about how hard not only councils in
general were hit but how hard
this council in particular was hit and
that was one of the reasons why we were
considered to be the fourth hardest hit
council in the country uh i have
councillor kettle and then council of
pemberton
um i'm about to declare an interest on
this two mr graft i'm an accountant
um and i have had a conversation with
councillor harvey and mr snow
on this paper
and it is very easy for accountants to
get into account and speak
and befuddle the unfinancially and
actually
it um but one thing i can say
is most of my life as an accountant has
been in explaining
financial matters to non-accountants
the royal finance director on the board
is rarely to speak to other direct
finance directors but to speak to
non-financed people
so i do think it is really important to
for non-financial people to be able to
understand the report
and i think there's something very
important here
which we need to celebrate and that is i
would like to
suggest that cabinet congratulates
the senior management team mr buckland
and his colleagues
for a phenomenal performance in the last
12 months
in producing a surplus and i do use the
word advisably
of a million pounds as a result of
very close control over expenditure
whilst we waited to see whether we were
or were not going to get grants
and the improving out turn over the last
four months from december
when it was minus four to um
february when it was -3 to where we are
now
at plus one i think demonstrates his
prudence and his team's prudence has
been
um a show of really careful
financial management and i think the
only
pity is that we can't see that
you have to be an accountant to dig that
out
but i think it is important firstly i
would like cabinet
to join me in congratulating mr buckland
and his team on what they've done
but i think there was a second issue
that we must
understand the difference between
discretionary transfers between reserves
and actual income
and expenditure and it is quite right
and i'm not suggesting
uh council harvey and his team haven't
been absolutely right in carrying
forward reserves
to or transferring to research to carry
forward for the future because clearly
there will be expenditures coming
forward
uh at some point which we need to
provide for
uh but i think at this stage we need to
congratulate mr buckland
and his team on a performance of one
million uh
improvement against budget and it's
definitely not where we were expecting
about 12 months ago when i think things
were looking very very
great indeed thank you councillor kettle
councillor harvey would you agree with
uh those congratulations for the surplus
of 1.1 million
i would indeed and i'm grateful for
councillor kettle to
to have made the point on my behalf
thank you can we record in the mini
summer congratulations
thank you very much and uh i'd echo the
the
that those congratulations because um
david and his team
have played a blinder throughout all of
this and
it is right to say that as an authority
putting out there
the impact on us did help to move the
dial in terms of central governments
thinking around supporting local
authorities
and in particular it's thinking around
supporting district councils the lower
tier because the default position at the
beginning of this thing was
will support the opportunity because
they've got health and social care
so if it was not for david and his team
and i do
particularly want to pay tribute to
george who was our interim
um finance officer um
there was a lot of midnight oil burn and
a lot of
thinking done and it was a great but
moving on just
as the real person in the room are you
not an accountant
um i i want to go back to councillor
junior's first
point um which uh was around
have we suddenly got a million quid
spare we can spend well the answer is
just for the avoidance of doubt no we
haven't got a million quid spare
that we can spend on anything else what
we are
just so i just thought i'd answer the
question that's been asked not the one
we wish we'd been asked
as as the examination board would have
it but no it is you know look we
we are it has been a moving feast and to
be fair
uh you know i i do acknowledge that um
you know the numbers have been all over
the over the place but they have been
all over the place for really good
reasons because
the the the the goal posts not only have
been moving we've got different shape
goal posts now
and i would observe that we're not
issuing section 114 notices
as has happened in the last seven days
we are this is not an authority that is
looking to
slash and burn and stop doing things
that make a difference to the lives of
our residents what we are is an
authority that
is prepared to take tough decisions and
david took tough decisions particularly
around
at the size of our establishment and our
budgeting
and the purpose of doing that is to put
us in the best
possible position so that we can
sustainably move forward
and continue to deliver the services
that our residents
want and need and i wish there was a
spare million quid we've got
to spend on lots of priorities that we
all share and have
but there ain't um we're still not
anywhere near out of the woods yet
uh but i am confident in uh in mr snow
and
uh mr buckland that we will get there uh
but yeah just for the avoidance of that
no
there is not a huge sofa that we've
suddenly found with cash at the bottom
of it
i think i would also add that we're
quite grateful to councillor harvey who
oversees this
[Laughter]
can i just uh add a piece of information
that um
uh it would be great if we did have
another million quid to
to uh decide what we wanted to do with
but the
the exact opposite is the case that we
are draining reserves
and it's it's salutary to remember that
in the case of slough
which issued at section 114 notice in
the past week
i think it's 2011 2012 their reserves
stood at
30 million and i think last year they
stood at four
they took their eye off the ball and i
could make a party political point about
it being a labour council since 1983
bar 2004 to 2008 when it was hung
but i won't
i am grateful you didn't make a party
political point councillor harvey
however counselor councillor pemberton
made some very good points
uh it really was important that we got
the message across about how
hard we had been hit and it was very
important we got across the message
about how hard district councils have
been hit
because what council harvey what sorry
what councillor pemberton said was
absolutely right
that initially all the support went to
the upper tier authorities
i would also agree that we are not out
of the woods yet
that in reality there is a lot still
to come from kovid 19.
i would also just like to add one more
point
we did at one stage ask mr hill
if he thought of this when things were
looking really dark
if he thought of issuing a section 114
notice
the stratfor district his response was
quite interesting
well normally had issue with section 114
he said i thought it didn't know what it
was doing and the council needed to be
informed
the problem is you lot are all over the
finances
and i think that is absolutely true we
do monitor the finances very closely
we do take an interest in it and if we
fail to take an
interest in it i am sure councillors
kettle and shenton would only remind us
of it
both of them being accountants so
are you going to tell me you're not an
accountant chris
[Laughter]
no i'm not there thank you mister all i
could suggest chairman
is in view of the comments which i'm
sure cabinet would endorse that we
actually admit
that the surplus of one million is due
to
the very uh effective work character of
miss buckland and his team
yeah and uh that wording should go in
the minutes
absolutely careful so
the recommendations on page 127
uh do we support the recommendations
cabinet
right
capital budget monitoring councillor
harvey again
uh having considered the year end uh
the picture for the whole last year the
next two papers merely consider
capital and revenue for the first two
months of the year so in in
relative terms they're lightweight uh so
to speak
um the purpose of the first paper is to
keep members informed of the progress
made over the first two months of the
year
in undertaking the council's intended
level of capital expenditure this year
paragraph 1.3 on page 139
refers to the intention to undertake
expenditure
this year of seven million pounds
including section 106 projects
taking into account additional funds of
231k budgeted for this year
this will result in the balance of this
of the council's accumulated capital
receipts
and grants being reduced over the year
from 5.7 million pounds to 5 million
pounds
paragraph 1.5 indicates that capital
expenditure of 910
000 pounds has either already been
undertaken or been committed
by the end of may in the first two
months of the year therefore the sum
spent or committed amount to 13 of this
year's
available budget of 7 million pounds
appendix 2
on pages 142-153
provides summary information concerning
various projects
yet to be funded as a result of section
106
agreements i asked therefore leader that
the current position on capital
expenditure
and income first two months of the year
to the to the end of may
2021 is noted
thank you
i don't think we need to take a vote
would that be correct mr grafton
thank you in that case moving on
uh item 12 once again councillor harvey
and finally i hope
the purpose of this report is to inform
the cabinet of the relevant
of the revenue picture of the council's
finances at the end of may
2021 i'd like to begin by asking members
to turn
to appendix 3 on page 165
this shows that the net budget to be
financed by the council this year
is 17.4 million pounds if we now turn to
appendix
2 on page 163 we can see that the budget
for the whole year
is for total expenditure of 27.1 million
pounds
and total income from various sources of
11.7
billion pounds the difference between
these two numbers
uh 15.4 million together with the net
cost of the cost
of benefits of 182 000 pounds
represents the total amount to be funded
from various sources i.e
15.6 million pounds as set out in the
appendix
in addition appendix 2 also sets out
that as a result of the kovid 19
pandemic the council has received grants
from the government of 12 million pounds
in these two months
and distributed 12.3 million pounds in
ways
consistent with the government's
intentions turning to the position at
the end of period 2 we can see that in
round terms
the council's expenditure of 6.7 million
pounds
was 912 000 pounds more than budgeted
despite the impact of the coveted
pandemic the success of the garden waste
scheme has resulted
in income of 3.4 million pounds to the
end of may
against the budgeted figure of 2.8
million pounds
the combination of these results means
that the net cost of services provided
in the first two months of the year was
280 000 pounds
above what had been budgeted section
three of the paper identifies that the
principal items are variants from their
budgeted figures during april may while
section 4 provides estimates
for the out turn for the year in full
managers and heads of service
continue to deal with the uncertainty
surrounding the fine-tuning of the
council's finances
and for the benefit of councillors junit
in particular
they are very aware of the need to
ensure that estimates of
future performance are as soundly based
as practicable
subject to any questions uh asked the
report is therefore noted
it's not really a question it's just a
statement that
one of the earmarked reserves was 20 000
for a play area of ulster
i have to announce um that the tenders
are now
gone out having the having the the local
group residence group has raised 25 000
to be able to match that and i would
like to be able to
put on record my our thanks to
craig bourne for the help that he's
given the residents group and
in giving us advice um so that we now
have gone out to tender
and we're expecting that play area to be
built
uh at the end of this summer thank you
councillor junaid
can we capture in the minutes and the
thanks to
craig lorne um
councillor kettle uh thank you mr
chairman
i would just um really remark rather
than anything else that
um uh council half is quite right the
terrific success in the greenway scheme
has is very identifiable
but if we look through um appendix one
uh or its alternate alter ego appendix
two
there are quite significant variances
within the different
departmental areas with
the benefits of the the greenway scheme
actually subsidizing
other areas where uh performance hasn't
been so
comfortable if i can describe it like
that um
and i think what i think that
demonstrates is that
as we move into a new financial year um
there are some you know very serious
challenges we want
what you know we need to face um over
that period and
and make sure that um you know again
uh that we're not blinded by the
benefits of the garden way scheme
uh and its impact on our overall
performance now i think you make a
valley point councillor kettle what i
would just say
is this is two months into the year in a
time of considerable uncertainty
council of pemberton i was really just
going to reiterate
the point for the benefit for the
benefit of everybody no there is not
loads of cash down the bottom of
a greenway spin uh we are only two
months in and uh
yeah so just for the avoidance of doubt
because we're ahead at the moment
uh it doesn't mean that there's uh
suddenly money to be released
thank you councillor pemberton
councillor harvey
can i just say that um there are more
accountants in the finance department
than there are around this table
and the people to whom we have just
given tribute
for their stewardship over the finances
last year are the same people
who are going to be having stewardship
over the uh finance of this organization
for this year
and i have every confidence in their
ability to deal with the operational
detail
thank you councillor harvey a point well
made
before we move to the recommendations i
would just draw
everyone's attention to point
12 2 in the conclusions on page 15
the council needs to continue to
maintain a proven stance in its
financial planning
uh with the council continuing to seek
to improve its reserves as a priority
the pandemic impact is not over yet
so with that cheering message from me
can i turn to the recommendations on
page 155
and can i have your agreement to the
recommendations members
of cabinet thank you
so moving on uh bancroft girl
agenda item 13 bancroft gardens
waterside and recreation ground
uh councillor barker i'm going to pass
this one to councillor shenton
in the same way as i passed another item
to him that was something he was fully
aware of
because i've got no idea about it even
though i now do assets
that was a hospital pass i can i can go
over i mean i can go over what the
report says
i think perhaps in that case we should
ask mr perks
thank you chairman for everybody's happy
i'm i'm a bit of a stand-in as well but
i can at least
take the cabinet through the report
because i do know a little more about it
in some
um what we have here is a report
suggesting that the
cabinets that give us um their
endorsement to advertise a number of
concessions
based primarily on the bancroft gardens
and the recreation grounds
we've traditionally had a number of
concessions in this area and we've
delayed the re-advertising of those
concessions
and putting them out to the market for a
couple of years now
whilst we've waited for industry the
recreation ground consultation to
conclude and then lastly the sort of the
riverside project consultation
what's presented to you in um there with
me a second
appendix one are a number of concessions
that officers are recommending to you
that you
allow us to um seek tenders for
um if we could turn to page 174
um i will ignore the first three for a
second
items four five six seven
eight and ten are renewals
existing concessions have been placed
for a long time so
i wouldn't i would hope you wouldn't
have any issues with those are things
like deck chair hire
the pleasure boats the rowing boats um
the ice cream concessions
the chain ferry um running through the
other ones we are proposing as part of
the riverside project to upgrade the
sort of mini golf area to make a
slightly more sort of modern attraction
there and what we're suggesting that we
seek is to allow
time for a partner to invest in that
that the 20-year concession is offered
for a sort of mini golf offer and
perhaps
of children's games we're thinking like
chess and drafts that sort of
offer there now with that one we would
with your blessings sort of seek
tenders for that and we will with the
portfolio holders sort of come go
through sort of
an appraisal process to come up with a
proposal that hopefully
ties in with the riverside project so
that covers that one off
item 11 relates to work
that we have done in the past where
we've had
for the summer season a sort of a small
fairground versus the children over over
the summer holidays so
that sort of seeks to formalize that
because it's been quite successful we've
experimented for about three to four
years now
so if cabinets are minded we would like
to make that permanent we're suggesting
um permanent honest at a temporary basis
it would come and go on the holidays
um item 12
over the row over that's a lot of the
route over the page is something that
cabinet have asked us to look at before
which is
the potential of introducing a drive in
cinema offer possibly on the overflow
car park area
we tried to do that on an experimental
basis last year unfortunately the
contract
didn't sort of come to pass because the
provider decided to stay at warwick
castle
for longer rather than come to us so
we're we're seeking um the cabinet's
blessing to sort of
see if we can get some interest in that
that's something you've asked us to look
at
[Music]
um sorry i'm doing a bit of a random
trip here because i'm going to go to the
ice skating which is item one
again an item that cabinet have
expressed interest in in the past
um and we're seeking your blessing to
look for a
provider of an ice cream for the for the
christmas season
located um on i think that was located
on the bancroft gardens
on an area there by the by the theater
um
so that's covered that one there are
two new concessions on items two and
three which is the item opposite the
encore which is sometimes known as the
dust bowl
where in the original sort of bancroft
remodeling we always had the idea of
um offering a sort of small food
concession there
so it's to see expressions of interest
whether anybody would like to take that
forward
um and the third item is for sort of a
mobile
vendor's license again this responds to
sort of comments that we've had from the
cabinet
you'll be familiar perhaps with the man
who sells wiggly worms and balloons
without
consent on on the ground of the bancroft
gardens
we do have a problem with that
type of activity and the idea of if we
let a small concession for something
that we wanted on there it may police
the things that we don't was that was
the thinking behind that
so we were we were going to sort of ask
for their expressions of interest to do
that
so that covers three so we've done one
two three four to
nine the chain fairy small children's
activity and finally
item 13 is really just to sort of
confirm
the current situation in terms of major
events we do
offer a rate at which you can hire the
the wreck ground
for things like we used to have the home
and garden show and things like that so
that's still available for sort of major
events if we wanted to hire the way we
tend to process that
is we publish a rate for it and we would
agree those with the portfolio holders
to whether they were appropriate and
being discovered if necessary
hopefully that's at least a start and
i'm happy to take any questions
any comments or questions members of
covenants
councillor junaid just from the ovum
scrutiny committee we drew attention to
the fact that uh ward members should be
consulted particularly since not some of
them were not just complete
uh renewals of concessions i understand
i understand that that has now
been uh resolved so again ovue and
scrutiny raised it and thank you for
uh taking that up counselor did you want
to call it yes it
has been right raised um and
satisfactory replies have been given
councilor parry thank you leaders just a
brief
a brief query um i note the
um the drive but the drive-in cinema
um is there a specific reason why we're
looking at this summer months is that
because of cars onto the recreation
just interested in sunset times and
normally cinema you do not need it to be
fairly dark
when you go to the cinema just a query
i'm not an expert in cinema but i under
some of the led screens they have this
yet
this is only based on the time we looked
to do it last time
they were happy to provide in the summer
months because people seem more
comfortable sort of coming out
then so they it seems they certainly
didn't work castle through june and july
and august last year so
it seems technically possible
i do believe there'll be plenty of
people in um
pub car parks and so on watching the
footy
technology seems to be capable thank you
councillor harvick wright
i see no more questions or comments so
uh are we in agreement with the
recommendation
on page 169 members of cabinet
fine thank you members of cabinet so
moving on uh agenda item
14 a bit additional business rates grant
funding
and this one i believe definitely is
council of art
it is that you will see as if by magic
that mr platts has appeared on the
screen
from his holiday show
turn him up again thank you david hello
hello good afternoon can you hear me now
leader
yes go on david excellent thank you um
well
hopefully um while we're in this meeting
um the prime minister
isn't offering up more schemes but let's
just
say that uh this item is to um
work closer with the growth hub on the
hopeful the arrival of the additional
funding that we're going to be awarded
in july
i think the main points i just wanted to
get over in this report was
that um if we had not spent all our
allocation of funding then we would not
have been able to access access this
extra 1.4 million so
um that's that's the real bonus for me
there are lots of councils out there who
haven't met their
target and so won't get the extra
funding um just to say
that we haven't had the actual amount
all the date when
this money is coming forward but uh
we've had um
as you will know we've had discussions
with the growth of and as soon as we get
final notification then we will uh
carry this forward and look to support
wider business across the district it
says in the report that we'll be coming
out to all members
to ask them for their suggestions and
recommendations as well
and the funding will be spent in
accordance with the growth of proposal
that's attached for your comments
any questions thank you mr platts
uh councillor pemberton
thank you leader and i'm going to be uh
supporting this recommendation but what
i really wanted to say
was that uh as we are recognizing
great performance uh i want us to put on
record
for the minutes the absolutely fantastic
performance
from david and his team throughout
the whole of this thing his team were
under pressure from minute one
you know from people who were wondering
how they were going to pay their council
tax from businesses that were
ringing up within three minutes of boris
coming off the
off the podium to know where their cash
was dealing with this stuff overnight
getting ready getting those answers out
and for coming forward with pragmatic
solutions when
there were delays around it systems from
central government being implemented
being able to get money out to
businesses and i know from my own ward
how many businesses have have been in
touch with me to say
how how fantastic the service was how
slick it's been
how we've been supportive and that is
absolutely down
to your team david and i want that
recorded in the minutes
because this i and this ability to
to be pragmatic and ensure that we are
in a position to take advantage of these
extra funds
is solely down to david bringing forward
a solution
so to enable us to support businesses
and residents
um so yeah let's record that
and uh i wholeheartedly support the
recommendation thank you
i think all cabinet will then build that
uh i do notice that uh actually
uh we have paid out over 70 million
which i think is a huge achievement so
our thanks to
you and your team mr platts thank you
very much thank you
council junior uh at the aov and
scrutiny committee similar thanks were
given
um that um in recognition that
um that the previous fund funding had
been delivered in a prompt manner
and that was enabling the allocation of
the additional funding to be granted
so that was also recognized and
monitored in the ovue and scrutiny
committee
one other item that came from the
overview and scrutiny committee
was and i believe it was it was um at
accepted would be that councillors would
be consulted and encouraged to put
forward suggestions for businesses
within their wards
to receive funding and that they should
be notified accordingly
thank you thank you councillor junior so
with that the recommendations on page
179
uh our council supportive i saw his
cabinet
supportive of the recommendations thank
you
members of cabinet so agenda item 15
this time it is counting
it's personal yes
it's not going to cancel
it's going to be councillor jennings
instead yeah thank you leader
um obviously the purpose of the report
is to provide the cabinet with details
on how the
council's active community
will strategy delivered over the next
three years at the end of 2018 the
cabinet endorsed the active community
strategy
for 2019 to 2024 including the delivery
plan for the first 12 months
this has now expired and the next stage
of delivery
uh needed to be considered since 2019
the provision of
active community services has moved on
and has been greatly impacted by
kovid 19. the provision of sports and
physical
activity is a discretionary service not
a statutory service
and is always the intention to work with
others to deliver activities
to make them more sustainable in the
long term and less reliant on the
council's limited
resources the district council
sports provision will now be provided as
part of the district council's
new 10-year leisure measurement
management contract with sln
with dedicated active communities member
of staff
one of the key elements of the slm's
proposal
is the use of the council-owned sports
pavilion on the red ground
in stratford-upon-avon as an outreach
hub to deliver activity
programmes together with the delivery of
outreach in more
rural and less active parts of the
district
slm service delivery proposals as part
of the new leisure contract
ensures that there is still a strong
focus on delivering key themes
of the strategy but removing much of the
cost and risk for those activities from
the council
obviously there will be a number of kpis
to monitor this
and the financial implications are that
this will give us a potential savings
of over 830 000 over the
next 10-year period the recommendations
are therefore that
the proposed active communities
programme
active community strategy delivery plan
2021-24
has outlined did appendix one be
approved in full
and the second recommendation is that
the council no longer directly provides
active community services such as the
high five activity programme
health walks and sports tournaments
councillor junaid uh yes the at the
opium scrutiny committee
it was requested that support for the
health walks be revisited
uh and that that why things like wider
benefits in combating loneliness and
isolation
be taken into consideration alongside
direct health
benefits and it was also suggested that
stratford youth council and
other youth group groups across the
district and be look
approached for input the deputy chief
executive agreed to take up those issues
i do hope that um the cabinet will also
consider whether or not these um the
views of the opium scrutiny committee
will be taken into consideration
thank you councillor cargill
thank you leader um right with my other
one of my other hats on
uh i chair the health wellbeing board in
ulster which is very active
we do a huge amount of activities
especially for the older
people but also for younger younger
residents as well
one of the things that we've not seen
though is any interaction with
slm in the past and i i mean
fully supportive of this document but i
would i would like to
have a comment from the portfolio holder
that they will the slm will be
encouraged
to sit on some of the committees and
boards that are for example the health
and well-being board that i sit on
so they can coordinate a number of the
activities within
an area because we do that now and
there's no sense in
having a silo approach to this let's all
work together on this and it could be
costs
beneficial to the organs both
organizations
so i'd appreciate if we can get that
emphasis to slm as part and pass this
contract thank you
do you wish to respond i'll certainly
look into that
counselor kettle um i mean
the council saving money is is an ex
excellent way forward
uh but clearly uh transferring of an
activity from the council to
um another body in this case a highly
commercial and successful
um a highly successful um
sports um and leisure provider um
what i would like to make sure is that
the level of activity that we are
providing as a council
will continue to provide about less slm
in the future
and that um that there will be kpis to
ensure
uh that in the event that it may not be
cost effective
for slm to provide them that that should
not be an excuse for them not to do so
uh and that going forward the same level
of service is provided to all residents
across the district
wherever they may be
i know that there are going to be a
number of kpis on that that will
certainly be monitored
thank you councillor shenton thank you
just to back up what uh councillor
jennings has just said
from the when this was in my portfolio
um i do know slm are held
to the api it's just as fit for help
with their apis
on waste management um julie and a team
are very strong
on on ensuring that they do do what they
say they're going to do
and i do know that in the in the active
community strategy but we talk about
working with partners to promote
and there is um there is a lot there are
lots of kpis they will not
be able to shy away from what we've
agreed or what's being breathed in the
contract
thank you councillor shenton um i think
it is interesting that if one reads this
report carefully it is apparent that the
world has moved on
and i think the reality actually is
we've got to move on with it
so that some of the things that were
done uh
are no longer quite as appropriate but
nevertheless
we should actually look very carefully
to see that we're not throwing away
anything that might be valuable with
that
recommendations on page 187
our members of cabinet happy with that
thank you members of cabinet in that
case we move on
to the on block items and these
are uh these are going to be
approved on block uh
urgent business i've got one champion uh
councillor shinto wanted to come in on
the climate change
um minutes you did mention it there all
right yes councilman
it's um it's just a minute number 68 on
urgent business and we say
first line due to the urgency of the
decision
required we have amended that to say
due to the urgency of the recommendation
the terms of reference or the climate
change is how
specifically today that we can recommend
we don't make decisions
thank you councillor shenton so we
capture that
so with that there is no urgent business
so thank you members of cabinet i
declare the meeting
closed at i believe 5
16.
thank you
you